let's look at this
from the uk's side okay so this
is not you can
so my uh
energy is gonna go right into him right
right on contact
not here and not on his shoulders
right into his center
so i'm addressing with a cochlear
projection
into his face i'm not here like this
getting ready to take my fall okay so
that will be drill one
rhino contact
it's against that that he tries to do
the technique
okay against that you do the technique
do technique dude
okay it's gonna expose the
the absence of the adhesion and the
a little bit so when he's he's doing
that
he's gotta get my center that was a
little high over my center
you gotta get my body it's still a
little high
but what you're doing is tilting to
doing this
it's gotta go
a little better
okay so he's doing that we'll do it one
arm at a time so
uh this will this is going to be the yin
arm
but yin has to be preceded by yaw
so this arm is actually going to reach
towards him before
yielding to that push
so i don't go here and then i go like
this because
i wouldn't be able to do that because
he's pushing into you that's going to
collapse
so as he comes in and reaches and then
gets out of the way of that push so do
the yin arm over here
you can't go like this it gets collapsed
here
it wasn't getting collapsed because the
guy was just holding your arms there
okay so he's trying to push into my body
and push i reach out and then go around
and push
the yawn arm this is the young arm
well if it's yawn it has to first be hit
so it absorbs
the push this way then he hits the
yonk there don't do it on this side it
goes
in down and around
he's trying to push center and it yields
boom and then
goes back on him so that's what i'm
trying to do is knock him
he's trying to do the push my center
one side's gonna warm the other side
yields
make sure
then as i go i want to
enter so i'm here
his hand is above his shoulder
and his other hand is by his shoulder by
here so let's just look at something
let's just look at that
what this does anatomically to him try
to lift your hand
you're going to see it's very weak
and then the same thing he's here he
tries to push his hand out here
it's very strong but let's put it back
it's very weak now because it's too
close to his body
okay so that's where i want to be
in this position here and
the energy is being
challenged from the side so don't seek
skeletal alignment here
you want that just like kokuho
you want that sideness to it but you're
remaining your own center so he's trying
to
push i just have a winged extension here
and i am letting the
so to speak the cheese sink everything
just drops
it's all very relaxed okay at the end
after you get here he's gonna
turn his body out and give me some
extra challenge okay
so he's doing his thing
i do my thing i end up in that same
thing
hand above his shoulder other hand by
his body
he took the fall then he kicks back and
i don't lean over here i just stay where
i am
here everything is relaxing he really
he i want that okay to really try to
muscle that
so it doesn't trigger me i just keep
releasing
the energy
okay so drill two uh let's clean up
noggin
let me just demonstrate some of the
techniques
you can just release everything release
everything
heart to my usual your muscles
okay now we're gonna get back to uk
okay
his side as naga is a reconciling of yin
and yang
and i am doing it too a reconciling of
yin beyond
so first my movement is governed by
a prescription i i had to do this
i had to attack the center
since this is called your whole i should
attack it with a coking projection which
you do every time and every
lucas roll
he's going to start one hand's got to
reach out yes
and one's going back and then they trade
places there you go
and you're going to fall into the front
inward position
elbow down you're going to fall into
this front inward position
this cocky is pushing
and this one is yielding on a curve
which means my body can't
does not want to be pulled because now
i'm not reconciling that
and also my body being ahead of this
is just being pushed i'm not reconciling
that energy either
so what i'm going to do is disappear
inside
around i'm going to disappear inside
that energy
a little bit more for real
nope
tie it again
more energy
so you have that 10 cup causes problems
is very weak
so this is going to require that i dive
under this here
not go around my leg
the yield underneath
let's try okay so uh let's let's explain
the first few reps there he had he had a
weak
um um so it's hard to reconcile the
energy that's not there but
the example is that he's pushing this
hand
and what i'm going to do is go
underneath his hand
okay that that's right so he he's he's
driving the back
hip and the back hips gonna go
underneath him
here and let that energy go by
okay um and what i'm doing
is de uh accelerating
i'm not um continually being accelerated
okay because to be continually
accelerated
is a young young clash he's he's
accelerating me because i'm pushing on
him he's
overpowering me okay i want to get rid
of this energy
um there's a reason for that well first
of all that's the art
but you'll see that you're going to gain
some benefits once your
chemi can get up at that level so first
of all
try to demonstrate it again so
still too weak you're trying not to fall
backwards
so now look how i'm going to disarm
the cull cube by rolling this hip
underneath it
now here's the thing um
when you do that you actually
stay in the movement longer
whereas for example he goes
and you come down here you're already
moving away
from the knot and
he is pushing you after a while you
start moving that way
and so you're less resistance
in terms of how long you wore resistance
okay so if i do
the barrel roll thing shoulder and hips
down
if he's strong enough go dude
eventually he gets it
but once i stay engaged
he's going to feel low you see that
weight stalled him
because i don't i don't yield by
running from him or being pushable to
him
i wait for him to
overpower it and that's what i yield to
it so
he'll feel a lot of weight as i go
you see he can't he can't even get the
technique
okay uh and then on the other side so
he has to improve his technique as
opposed to
he goes like this and he's already
falling there's no more technique
he's fallen away
there was nothing there
but the downside of that is
when i do the technique right my uk has
no chance
to keep their grip and stop getting beat
up
okay so meaning when i'm not relying on
that okay that's falling
um my technique gets really hard like
for him to
try to stay in front of so we're going
[Music]
he couldn't move and the grip got
compromised because
his weight is pulling against the grip
okay
and so he just he just kind of get
hit you see
his body keeps resisting the energy
every time
you would probably say that is that like
two to five percent right
yeah i'm not here going you
[Music]
his body is too still and so his grips
get pulled out because his body is not
moving
okay so then you always have to train
slow
um and he just gets beat up for an hour
this way
okay so let's try it the other way okay
so that
that training should should look like
this okay so i'll be there
okay you go through all those steps work
on all those things so
uh i don't make it easier for him to
throw me if he doesn't give me anything
to reconcile then he's just gonna feel
all that weight of that
longer than normal
engagement of my mouse okay so taking my
fail here or there
doesn't it doesn't matter
so that's a failure so you let go
good
about me
okay
so